so Ruth pert were here at let's collect
Romania how are you enjoying it today
very much so I popping me a little bit
chilly having a great day it's my first
one so it's yeah exciting met some
lovely people and it's been big cuticles
for you of amerli and as well people
love the show I mean it was so popular
and then people came from all over the
world to watch you fill in France it's
all done playing yeah and then we had he
has crazy every year there were more and
more people at the castle which was just
brilliant I think there are many shows
where you can see it being filmed so it
was it was great we had I mean hundreds
sometimes hundreds and it was it was our
kind of rock star moment you got out the
car there were people screaming for you
and it was great I mean that's a great
thing about being the shows you have so
many people and so many fans and turning
up here you know you see people there's
always the fear that people go we don't
care anymore but you know it's been so
far it's been a great day yeah why do
you think it has been so popular over
the years so you had took five series
but didn't worry you know it's
long-running and how do you think it
changed over the years as well I think I
think was popular because it's just a
kind of just classic storytelling you
know it's something that would never go
out of style people love those they are
Furion legends amazing and you know on a
base level you have you know girls
dressed in beautiful dresses and you
have guys fighting with swords so it
appeals to everyone little girls love it
boys love it and it's Family TV which
there hasn't been much of in recent
years which seems silly but you know
have all these reality TV shows and they
have their own fans and followings in
there
I can see why people like them but it's
very few shows that family sit down and
watch and it appeals to so many people I
think it definitely better not just cuz
I joined ensues - that was a big big
reason I think it got bad about the look
of it I think you just have to even if
you just look at the difference between
Episode one and Episode five oh sorry
series one to his five just the look is
amazing we change format of filming the
stunts were better the CGI was I think
fantastic I mean you know for a British
TV show to have those those effects and
it was quite exciting and the actors we
had and the scripts got better and just
the look of it I think was it was just
every year they wanted to be bigger and
better and I think they did achieve that
so it was good to end before it went
down
how did you feel about where it ended
both for the show and for your character
as well well I was great to stay alive
we were there a few survivors yeah and
it's like this point do you want a
really mighty death scene but yeah I I
think as I said earlier I think it's
great to leave it on a high and I think
that what I like has it's been it's had
a mixed reception and people love the
end we're sad by it and they and some
people went oh I found that the very own
quite strange or some people loved it or
it's great I think it's great to have a
show that people feel so strongly about
and the character so yeah good to end on
a high and and it's sad but and I felt
so people watching on Christmas Eve as
well yeah the night before Christmas to
have all those deaths and you're like
you can't do that but it's great and
it's still shown all around the world
you know it's in America a few months
ago and you know it's huge they're huge
all around the world and so people are
still coming to it and it's a show that
people are still starting to watch it is
repeated now and so it constant get a
new fan scene being here the age of
people were meeting it is such a buried
this so that's a big part of the show as
you meet with such different
two fans is great I do think this
husband talked over me I haven't there
of maybe a Merlin movie what do you
think the chances of that would being
what would you like to see happen Wow
I'd like to happen what the lights is
obviously this shows to be all about
Leon my character may be slightly biased
ninety minutes of that I think I think
people could you people the face that
ninety minutes yeah I think they would
love that maybe we could make it three
hours and a trilogy of the the events of
Leon I would see it my mum would say PC
Jack flew into direct yeah I'm he's
desperate I know he's that's what to
work with me yeah I don't know if it
happened in terms of I know there was
talk of it I can be great it's whether
it has the I think it has the fan base I
think be great to come back to it but
what's been great and it shows the
caliber of the cast is pretty much every
one of the main the main cast have gone
on to big things you know straight after
it's finished and done that's about the
show so I'm sure getting the whole group
together again would be really hard but
we're also you know we're all so close
we'll see I'd love to the gap it would
happen but it would have to be really
good because they want to bring it back
and disappoint people so we'd love to
see that I'm sure and loads of fans
would love to see it I mean what was it
like working with everyone on the show
you mentioned how close you guys were
cause Kali
and Bradley everyone else yeah it was
wit swigs it really is like it was a
family and you know it is cliched you
have to say oh we all got him really
well but we actually did and I oh sorry
I think you see you know the fact that
I've seen everyone since and you know
hung out with them all it's in a few of
us going to Australia next month and you
know Leia you know Tommy were picking me
up from the airport and I saw Bradley
out there a lot and angel I see all the
time and Katie when she's in London I
see her and : I'm going to see him in a
play and we meet for lunch and it's
really great and and you know Anthony
helped me you know taught me where to go
in LA and all these things so we're all
it really is a close-knit group and we
are like a family we can wind each other
out we spend so much time with each
other but it is we genuine is it's great
you know we've met some friends that
we're gonna keep in touch with for life
you know so it's great I did hear a
little rumor that you guys spent longer
in makeup and hair then the ruin did can
you scorch or prove this rumor I think
there's any video footage I can say is a
complete lie we literally wake up roll
out of bed and look that fantastic I
think it wasn't far off between me and
Owen you know I had you know wasn't very
I didn't take that long to do the hair
but yeah maybe we were quite we've maybe
spent a bit too tired too long but that
was I think the makeup girls wanted to
have a some chair just to boost morale
we were done in like two minutes it was
fine yeah it was great
60 seconds yeah definitely no I think
yeah there was those rumors going around
but I I'm going to pretend that they
weren't true we believe you just look
forward to from you next week oh gosh
I did a little show for the White Queen
I did a little guest on that amazing
script amazing cast and then did a
couple of other little commercials and
things just kind of trying to pick the
right projects really because when
you're in a show like moaning you want
it to be you want to be your next move
to be big so the White Queen was a
natural progression it'd be nice to go
and put on a pair of jeans in something
and be and get a haircut yeah so just
trying to trying to do something good is
worthy of the next stage of Merlin and
that's what you know a lot of people
have been doing so it's keeping make
sure the fans who are so loyal are
pleased with the next move you don't
want to just go oh you're doing that now
that's a shame you know you want to find
a good scripts and good projects so yeah
we'll see we'll see
and finally what would you like to say
to the fans who are watching listen to
you out there
Wow just thank you for being as loyal
and as fantastic as you've been and
keeping the show alive five years and
going from strength to strength so just
thank you Reuben Thank You Todd yeah
thank you very nice
you